tu m'entends attends je vais les haut
parleurs tu bouges pas je n'allais au
parlant de téléphone ne bouge surtout
pas derniers réglages avant le grand
direct avec la guadeloupe à vesoul il
est 14 heures là bas 9h du matin une
grande première pour ces élèves en
classe de seconde professionnelle au
lycée pontarcher il ne participe à une
émission de radio à distance avec des
collégiens ou a loupé un on a plein de
fait en fait ça à fil conducteur où on a
notre test pour pousser repérer quand
est ce que nous on va devoir parler lire
la une
débriefing où on s'entraînait à préparer
les questions c'est pas un peu les
questions étaient mal formulées ou mal
exprimée on sera entraîné pour mieux les
préparer un projet qui a débuté en
décembre dernier avec des échanges avec
ses autres viennent aujourd'hui même si
c'était le grand jour de l'émission
la technique a fait des siennes les
aléas du direct
ça s'appelle très clairement entre
lynette des petits problèmes de
technicité difficile d'échanger en
direct mais des vidéos ont permis de
découvrir l'univers des uns et des
autres comme avec cette présentation des
jeunes guadeloupéens à de leur collège
une belle aventure humaine née une
amitié entre deux professeurs en haute
saône et en guadeloupe
on s'est retrouvés de mon côté avec un
programme sur les catastrophes
naturelles à l'année dernière
le cyclone maria a touché la guadeloupe
donc l'idée est venue de mettre mes
élèves de seconde en relation avec ses
élèves de 4e pour qu'ils ne fassent part
de leur ressenti de leur vécu
même si tout ne s'est pas passé comme
prévu dans ce grand rendez-vous promis
laventure va se poursuivre de nouveaux
directs sont à prévoir dans les
prochains mois